retrouver le chemin du marché avec
masques gants et solutions hydro
alcooliques pour les organisateurs
semblent plus simple en tout cas depuis
la mise en place du confinement pour
cause de crise sanitaire
on passe vite fait en sorte indiqué la
supérette ça on perd du temps quoi
faisant que bon moi je suis
professionnel de santé cqp que je passe
avec mon âge j'ai pas trop de soucis
certains surface mais d'autres il faut
attendre pour pousser la grande que quoi
c'est la première fois que je viens mais
oui je suis content j'avais pas trop au
magasin non plus donc voila quoi
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'eau
que
au supermarché mais là ça va
effectivement c'est plus fluide 10
heures tout ou presque s'est envolé le
marché agricole du nord atlantique mais
une production limitée durement frappée
par une sécheresse exceptionnelle la
fermeture ces derniers jours plus
événementielle matic c'est double peine
pour les agriculteurs oui il ya une
baisse énorme de gaffer c'est une maigre
au cern jeunes suivent l'évolution est
assez inquiétante donc là je vois c'est
le trouver des solutions pour essayer de
voir ses yeux plutonium pour quelques
temps on est sûr moins 60% entre tous
mes collègues la du marché agricole et
ben nous sommes au moins 60 % de perte à
en matière de d'argent moins de revenus
60% dans tout le moins d'heures de masse
manque d'eau des sols asséchés
les agriculteurs sont d'ores et déjà
inquiets pour les six mois à venir à
laquelle vous planter c'est quasiment
c'est un risque énorme
bon voilà j'ai perdu énormément le jeu
bon je suis paumé des choses comme ça
d'autres spéculations mais le plan une
fois à terre dans deux jours les boules
et là on ne peut pas planter on peut pas
planter parce que il fait trop chaud
la moine telle loi on s'organise l'a
peut-être pour une pénurie pénurie de
denrées
il faut il faut il faut il pas c'est
parce que là on sait pas on ne sait pas
vraiment ce marché a néanmoins prévu
d'accueillir les consommateurs du nord
atlantique samedi prochain